have you seen this insane video of a
giant Chinese Coast Guard boat ramming
into a smaller boat from the Philippines
this is just one part of China strategy
to control the South China Sea which is
this really valuable water which China
claims almost all of now of course no
one in the world recognizes this claim
and all of China's neighbors have claims
that cut through China's claim that
Filipino boat that was run into by the
Chinese Coast Guard was actually in
Filipino economic Waters but crucially
this boat was carrying supplies to a
tiny little Island where the Philippines
has intentionally crashed an old warship
to kind of plant a flag and claim it as
theirs and there's a bunch of sailors
who just live out here China does not
like this hence going and bullying the
supply ship that's going to refuel them
China has their own Island Building
operation which they use to put military
assets all over the South China Sea and
every year they get more and more
aggressive in asserting their dominance
over the entire South China Sea which
could very easily escalate into a
broader conflict if you want to better
understand global politics follow along
for more